quel a été le périple de Mohamed
mogouchkov dans les heures qui ont
précédé son passage à l'acte le vendredi
13 octobre dernier tout commence au
petit matin dans l'une des bares
d'immeuble de la Reise une cité
populaire à l'ouest d'aras la famille
mogoukov originaire du caucas russe s'y
était installé il y a 8 ans ce matin-là
Mohamed m 20 ans quitte de bon heure
l'appartement familial dans sa poche
deux couteaux qu'il s'était procuré au
préalable sur internet le jeune
radicalisé n'a alors qu'un objectif se
met la terreur dans un lieu qui l'exècre
par-dessus tout l'école mais il n siend
pas tout de suite à 8h53 il est aperçu
dans une grande surface arageoise en
train de s'acheter à un téléphone
portable quelques instants plus tard il
monte dans un bus municipal et disparaît
c'est à 10h37 sur le parvis de la gare
que sa silhouette surgite à nouveau
devant les caméras de vidéosurveillance
il se dirige alors à pied vers le
monument mort un imposant édifice de
calcaire qui trône au centre de la place
du Maréchal Foch c'est le lieu qu'a
choisi l'islamiste pour tourner la vidéo
qui sera ensuite retrouvée par les
enquêteurs dans son téléphone portable
dans cet enregistrement audio Mohamed m
après avoir Pr traité sièrement à
l'émire de l'État islamique développer
sa haine de la France des Français de la
démocratie toujours dans cette séquence
il apporte son soutien aux musulmans
d'Irak d'Asie de Palestine sans
toutefois directement relier son acte
aux récents événements israéliens
précise le procureur c'est alors que
l'assaillance slance boulevard Carno il
n'est plus qu'à quelques mètres de la
cité scolaire gambeta Carno où lui-même
avait été scolarisé et patiente jusqu'à
l'intercours à 11h quatre professeurs
sortent de l'établissement parmi eux
Dominique Bernard enseignant de français
aussitôt Mohamed m se jette sur lui et
le poignarde au cou et à l'épaule des
blessures dont l'enseignant décédera
avant sa prise en charge par les secours
c'est alors que David VG un professeur
deeps tente de s'interposer il reçoit
plusieurs coups de couteau au visage
mais se relève et se rue à l'intérieur
du lycée pour lancer l'alerte courz
courz par pitié auraaiit-il alors crié
selon le témoignage d'un adolescent près
de 2000 élèves se trouvaient alors dans
l'établissement tous se barricadeent
dans les classes et retiennent leur
souffle une fois dans la cour il a tenu
les propos suivants au professeur qu'il
poursuivait qui te donne l'air que tu
respires qui est le seul Dieu la scène
qui suit a été filmé par un élève et
largement relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
on y voit l'agent territorial Jacques
Davoli s'interposer muni d'une chaise
face au terroristes mais l'agent tombe
au sol et reçoit plusieurs coups de
couteau notamment au thorax à ce
moment-là un des témoins qui cherchait à
joindre la police se fait interpell par
Mohamed m appelle Marian appelle ta
République lui lancet-il le terroriste
se dirige ensuite vers le bureau du
proviseur mais ne l'ayant pas trouvé il
fait marche arrière après quelques
altercations avec l'équipe pédagogique
le forcenet tente finalement de
s'échapper de l'établissement c'est
alors qu'il est interpellé par les
forces de l'ordre au bilan un mort et
trois blessés dont le pronostic vital
n'est toutefois plus engagé transporté
dans les locaux des services
antiterroristes à levalloispet Mohamed m
s'est montré peu locaste face aux
enquêteurs il a été déféré ce mardi
devant le juge d'instruction ainsi que
son jeune frère et son cousin de 15 ans
mais les investigations ne font que
démarrer les enquêteurs de la
sous-direction antiterroriste et de la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure ont désormais faire la
lumière sur une série de questions
depuis quand cette attaque a-t-elle été
organisée d'autres personnes ont-elles
participé à son élaboration et surtout
aurait-elle pu être
[Musique]
évitée